Reggie Miller on the call for the
Warriors rockets game for last night
he'll be heading to Oakland game 5
Wednesday at 10:30 Eastern on TNT good
morning reg how you feelin man those
guys are you just listed man they were
pretty good Jerry West Michael Jordan
and LeBron James and I was the Kevin
Durant has been spectacular in these
playoffs to me I've always been a big
proponent of how do guys perform under
duress and what Durant has done on the
road in these playoffs has been
absolutely special I want to bring back
a road game for you in the playoffs it
was 1995 on this day when you had that
great comeback against the New York
Knicks you had eight points in nine
seconds what don't I know about that
moment in your career well I think
breaking huddle being down six I was so
upset personally you know I felt that we
were just gonna give another road game
away to the Knicks because we had not up
to that point then successful versus New
York in the garden especially in the
playoffs so being down six I said okay
we can get it click to rehear you know
we can start to play the free throw game
I did know that they didn't have any
timeouts so you know a bad pass here a
turnover you know we would have a shot
but my first inclination was just to
make the first three foul you know and
hope if they missed free-throws so I
make the first three and understanding
that they didn't have any timeouts left
and once I saw Anthony Mason take the
ball out I knew I was like okay well we
have a shot possibly I know people want
to talk about the shove on Greg Anthony
I still will go to my grave and say that
he slipped and then the past came to me
which I was shocked and I knew instantly
I had to get behind the three-point line
because people a lot of people say why
didn't you just go in for a layup we
were down three
vl1 absolutely not I'm getting behind
the three and if I make her miss then so
be it but no I was getting behind the
three but you also took the shot from
the almost the same exact area so you
hit back-to-back threes from I'm gonna
guess your footprints were probably in
the same place yes they were and what
made it even sweeter is they were in
front of my good friend spike no
probably having a heart attack during
that moment and it's funny because
during the game obviously it was so loud
it was packed it's the garden a lot of
the Knicks fans had left when they were
up six so it was pretty empty in there
and then next thing you know I mean it
was like bedlam and you know I'm doing
that they choked and which was probably
a mistake on my part because they
smacked us in game too but it was it was
it was a great moment and of course
Michael Jordan overshadows you on this
day because it was on this day that Mike
Bulls against the Cavaliers and poor
Craig Ehlo is hanging in air and then
Mike Kang's a little bit longer and then
hits that jumper that eliminates the
Cleveland Cavaliers one of the great
teams in NBA history that didn't win a
championship that Cleveland Cavalier
team is up there they were loaded Marc
price he talked about ehlo Brad
Daugherty Larry Larry Nance yeah I mean
that team from top to bottom but hey
young black Jesus Michael Jordan that
shot is so iconic because I remember
watching that and when he was going
first of all the fact that they were
able to get him the basketball because I
thought that was gonna be a turnover he
faked left right left and got the
basketball and a couple dribbles and I'm
like well he's coming down isn't he
coming down and then when he made this
shot I mean the reaction that was pure
Michael Jordan absolutely Pierre Michael
Jordan if you had to bet on one reg
Celtics win their series with Milwaukee
or the Rockets beat Golden State which
one roster did you take the Rockets
beating golden
these are two teams that are very
familiar with one another and what we've
seen up to this point is what both teams
do they they held serve I will say this
going back to the bay area and we have
game 5 Kevin Harlan Allie LaForce and
myself on Wednesday what the Rockets are
doing because they're getting
contributions look James Harden's been
great Aaron Gordon to me has been the X
Factor because of his scoring but to get
contributions from Shumpert Austin
Rivers off the bench Steve Kerr and the
Warriors they are getting absolutely
zero from their bench and it's going to
take the longer this series goes it
favors Houston because they're able to
use Nanae off the bench and they're
getting breaks for some of their guys
and they're playing small and PJ Tucker
again doing all the little things to
help Houston win the starting five is
getting taxed too many minutes for Andre
Iguodala and they are making klay
Thompson and Steph work at the defensive
end and to me that is affecting their
offense and they have dead legs and
their tired legs because they have to
defend they are constantly putting stuff
and pick and rolls and making him guard
Gordon Chris Paul and at times James
Harden and to me it is wearing him down
the most unstoppable player in the
postseason this years who I'm still
gonna go with Kevin Durant
but what Kawhi has been doing with
Toronto and what we've seen from James
these last two ballgames those three
players are able to do whatever they
want on the floor but to me Kevin Durant
is at a different level you know you
hear me keep saying how you want to
where you want it he can get anywhere
you want on the court and because that's
at 7-foot frame long arms he can post
you up he has that Dirk Nowitzki where
he puts that leg up and you there's no
defense for it so they're switching they
switch capela on them they got a taller
guy thinking that length is going to
affect him he drives right by them so I
would go with Kevin Durant
you know dare I not mention Yanis who
put up what 39 last night in 16 but to
me he doesn't have the offensive you
know repertoire that those other three
guys have in hardened and and cly and
Katie
his all-around game I think is better
than probably you know those three guys
but in terms of scoring I'm gonna go
with Katie talking to Reggie Miller reg
on the call with game four last night
game five Wednesday night at 10:30
Eastern on TNT finished this sentence if
the Celtics don't advance
I do think changes are coming I think
Danny Ainge number one I hope he gets
better I know he had a mild heart attack
I think major changes could be coming I
think that you may see Anthony Davis in
a Celtics uniform I think they wanted to
hold on to some of those younger guys
and Tatum and Brown but looking at these
playoffs I mean it's not like they're
really doing anything and I think if you
can get Anthony Davis and this is Kyrie
stays you think he does I do not you
know I don't need to do not I I do not I
think he's he's headed for Madison
Square Garden along with KD and maybe
the number one pick if they get that I
think that's that's just my personal
opinion if the Warriors don't advance I
think it's gonna win or lose I think
that's gonna be a new look Golden State
team I think Katie is out the door the
question mark is going to be clay you
know I've read comments that if he's not
offered to max he's out the door
boogy cousins because of the injuries I
don't think he's gonna get a major deal
but I can see him staying now I can if
he's going to take a you know a price
cut a salary cut I can see him staying
now but I definitely think KD is gone my
question is going to be what is clay
gonna do would you give him a max deal I
I would not give him a max deal I think
he's asking for five years 190 if I can
get him five years 170 175 and he's
happy with that I don't know if I would
give him a max deal but he certainly let
me say that he has certainly earned it
and if he can get it elsewhere I'm sure
he will but I don't know how we give him
the max but why is it that clay gets
credit he doesn't get blame
you know Steph gets credit and blame
Katie gets credit in blame Draiman gets
credit in blame well the three guys you
just mentioned to our former MVPs is one
of the defensive player of the year and
really the heartbeat and sound of the
Warriors clay is great that's why I
don't know do your third or fourth best
sounding board I don't know if you can
give him a max he's earned it three
championships don't get me wrong and one
of the greatest shooters of all time but
he is not the focal point of that
Warriors team right now it's Katie
number one it was even Katie when he
joined two years ago yeah it was
wrestler then Steph Steph is the face
and will always be the face and will go
down as the best player ever in a Golden
State Warriors uniform and I think the
sounding board is is Dre month so the
reason why I think clay you know flies
under the radar is because you know we
focus on those other three first that's
why I'm not sure that's Amex
give your fourth best player a max deal
yeah that's that's I understand the
logic thing you know behind that with
what you're saying but you know then I
wonder if if they slide him or he feels
like it's a slight and they say hey
could you take five years 160 million
then all of a sudden he goes you know
let me see what the Clippers are
offering here cuz you know Kauai could
use a wingman here
and then maybe have something like that
Alvin he's gone I can't fault him there
look all you need is one team even one
team to offer you that he's earned the
right to jump [ __ ] he's won three
championships so it's okay if he goes to
the Clippers he's going home you know
he's from the Southern California area
grew up there so I mean I can't I won't
fault that just like I'm not gonna fall
term not offering him to max I know you
gotta go but I did want to ask you about
the the Monty Williams situation that
you know Adrian was around he said that
he turned down the Lakers or he took the
sun's job and the Lakers are surprised I
I always thought it was a foregone
conclusion tyloo's getting the job but
did did Monty Williams make the right
decision here if you had the Lakers or
the Suns which job would you take
Phoenix I'm okay with that young core a
Booker Aten of a potential top let's say
three pick it's a great location to live
to play it's a great fan base you don't
know what's going on with the Lakers you
don't know what's going on the Lakers
front office the scouting don't don't
get me wrong you've got LeBron that's
great
but right now that's it there's a lot of
heavy expectations and that to me I
think ty lue is fit for that job you
know he understands LeBron he's won a
championship with them yeah I think
that's a good fit but if I'm Monty
Williams I made the right decision for
the Valley of the Sun I know you got a
plane to catch
we'll be watching on Wednesday night
Thank You reg the you know are you are
the best and eight no this we are here
for you we love you whatever you need
from the fifth Danette I'm here for your
brother all right
I am here for you thank you wrench
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on VR
or download the Dan Patrick show app